non so come sarà l'italia e benvenuti
solita stress oggi mamma challenge
slimer con le mistery box abbiamo buddha
di scatole misteriose oggi uno alla
volta che avremo pescarle da bendati e
qualsiasi cosa
qualsiasi cosa ci sia dentro ma perché
dovremo metterla ve lo slime perché
questo qualsiasi cosa qualsiasi perché
c'è qualcosa di schifoso cosa e bussole
brutto dobbiamo stare attenti a non
salire la mistery box sbagliata perché
questo lo slide potrebbe uscire una
schifezza sempre vincerà chi farà lo sly
un po più bello e stampi nel video
potrete votare qua mi metterò il
sondaggio potrete votare se ho vinto io
che non si sono team azzurro o yacht in
rosso
allora mettetevi comodi prendete i pop
corn e iniziamo
come mai ok allora chi inizia con un
pesante caduta con carta forno è stato
esiste orbitale deve dare unicorno oggi
super un ricordo gigante penso allora
devi pescare una scatola occhi chiusi e
ferito dai una così cospicua quello che
senti che ti attira di più questo pesa
tantissimo certo questa è l'aria gare
dobbiamo fare lambo xing e assieme ho
preso la scatola perde tempo chiedo come
adesso si è trasferito negli store i
botti aggiungere link che ha fatto
piacere a dio come se il mister
scelgo con il cavallo giusto allora
comprende allora io cominciare
non so come non ti è capitato almeno te
capitato a te che cosa mi amò con l'hiv
verde super verde che strano che capita
a tutti questa borsa e poi c'è il premio
di consolazione inflitto viola dai pro
dopo quello di me come diventa aggiunta
alla colla almeno i glitter i glitter lo
possono migliorare tanto bello
presidente di consolazione e questo
mondo giungono mio dovere per forza deve
per tutta tutta uscì nel lucroso e come
faccio a metterlo meglio se il solito
perché così si mischia meglio con la
colla siri sarà anche le dita non è
facile
ecco l'invito di rimanere di scalare con
loro fare non veniva fuori sembra mozzo
di troll
[Risate]
era il meglio che sotto che si mescola
bene
tutto questo perché non ti senti lato il
dito nel naso
penso ha detto mischiando bene benissimo
allora vediamo un po cosa se nella mia
scatolina a casa da allora 22 il
colorante verde ovviamente in colorante
verde cosa ci si poteva aspettare le
proprie valere per carità metto il nuovo
nuovo bellamente abbiamo avuto due anzi
più ce n'è più
al 34 almeno 38 è ancora imparando tanto
sta barando
adesso si potrà tantissimo
guardatevi del cardinale ha messo tanta
anche turi eventi poco
daremo così neanche si nota mette in
gioco il bene o fa di rho lo stesso
quando ti capiterà qualcosa di schifosa
e dovrei mettere tutto il mio messaggio
il 3 prometto pinocchio guardatemi sono
più male
come la maledizione del verde il sole
mio ancora a pezzettoni di tron dai sei
pronto a pescare tornano dai sono ok
festa hai fatto la tua scelta definitiva
note allora gigante trono ha definiti
c'è un ormone strano questo però va bene
ok la salina l'aprire si è fatto chiedo
questo la risposta giusta ma col tempo
piccolino è piatto e di niente vediamo
un po
[Musica]
futuro che si spera che dentro maturo
tutto il nostro video di esperimenti
fatti in casa saprete cosa però è un
modellabile piacere messo nato sla e che
può essere messo però una brutta fine ai
noti fatti sono bruno minuti di vedere
come città dentro il live come diventerà
lo slime stati affezionare troppo perché
troppo resta all'interno tutto però so
che lui tagli verrà tagliato proprio la
passione attenzione perché poco troppo
poco onorevole altro attento come locali
mari potrebbe esplodere addirittura
attenzione al passato ma tutto devo
ammetterlo no allora dentro abbiamo
farina di semola ci darà retro live anni
facciamo la pizza diventerà delizioso
che tu slide werder un bozzo di tron e
farina pronti per riformare la coppa
per torta proverbi che utilizza il via
pola dai magari esce bello lo stesso
speriamo ma batte ormai grazie possibile
che esca il cimitero piano di volo anche
dai forni che brutto allora tocca a me
apriamo la nostra mistery box vediamo un
po che abbiamo nessuna è però dei
pallini perché l'iter color pastello
l'altro me le avete regalato e voi ai
firma copie grazie
ora si vedrà ancora meno il verdetto che
se oggi la vediamo che bello bellissimo
color menta quando ancora detta l'ultima
parola
adesso potrei anche rovinarlo con i
prossimi ingredienti penati vediamo casa
questa volta essendo le costruzioni ecco
che cosa è questo io ti posso dire
niente ma un colorato della camorra e
sento che tocca ma era uno stato di
moroso preso ma il rischio furbissimi
fischio fatto è bello avere le mani
sporche di molto di droga allora io
volevo prendere una piccola ma dove li
nascoste che capretta la tua cosa vorrà
leggere briatore adesso questo molti
interessi
ecco se n'è uno piccolo prendo questo è
una scatolina tonda via
non vediamo un po vedi un po glitter
rosa abbia fortuna abbiamo pregato di
internet in mobilità
forse un po a salvarlo questo modo di
troll che contiamo portiamo divertenti
non riusciamo ad impararlo un po questo
smart di colore grigio
ci vuole un palo non riesce a trovare un
colorante rai fortunato da trovarla
colori grigio orribile abbiamo un po
quotazione nella mia scatola 123 punti
colorati allora ne ha ma perché è nero
la minociclina che color news line con
la battaglia dal mio gara grigio e poi
capito anche tu
un premio di consolazione cioè il blues
vediamo un paragone lato etico di
piccolo ma a 4 in te da bravo proprio
non colori anche le palline seno alla
rovina tutte adesso diventa color
cioccolata a colorando anche alcune
palline il brutto salvo tornare ai
minuti bella e colorate non è vero hai
più berlino rt clip
speriamo che cambi un po bacchettone
vento da artisti è cambiato e sono
rimaste poche scatole ok l'altro il
monti marcato la piccola son rimaste
quattro scatole che vi aspetta e vedrai
mostra infortunata per una scatola in
più all'ora di mischiare gattopardo
prendo questa che da prima che la
toccavo the ok ok siamo pronti a un po
cosa c'era stato linea di vita ci sono i
glitter e allora ci sono i glitter verdi
il colore viola un maledetto c'è qua
dentro
capitolo subitissimo la mente a mettere
colore viola così mi diventa un bel
galaxy è fatto troppo ancora con questo
cala affetti adesso vedrai che uscirà un
galaxy diano la guardo ne sono sicuri
[Musica]
però ancora che sempre la farina 90
diventa un cupcake ai mirtilli però
quello che può il colore cani segugi e
cani e gatti
vediamo come dio cioè non si chiede il
giusto diventato video del mio dipende
perché qua potrete fare qualcosa di
stupendo che a me lo cambia e diventa
più bello il mio ma guarda che guardo
che ha 4 chiamare display mirti sembra
uno yogurt ai mitili siamo pronti
[Applauso]
che sfiga tra l'altro gigantesco vede
anche bravissimo se era meglio se mi
capitava trasparente sciolto che questo
neanche come come attivarlo fantastico
tra le zebre così fortunata numero
enorme su questa cosa c'è dentro nera
fatidico un po no perché non sia un
pezzo di busco benatti iscrivetevi
commenti secondo voi cos'è questa cosa
bene fantastico ora vado a unire questo
vulcano di slide verde
meno male non è troppo duro vediamo un
po che si fa che ti sarai mai
[Musica]
abbiamo già un vincitore
ecco il 20 ma non mai perché magari una
volta che lo attivo diventa un
bellissimo riciclino da tutta qua a
metterne altre cose o come farai ad
attivarlo si stanno sciogliendo quindi
forse riesco ad attivarlo però sono
rimaste tre scatole in più l'ultima
scatola la divideremo quindi se li bene
c'è la procura si ok non c'è bisogno che
vi penso perché sono due e si capisce e
non so perché ma l'albero
lei mi fa un po paura non ha storia
fatto che sia così bella e lucente
questa carta l'avevamo ancora grave
perché è troppo lontano dalla quindi in
toscana non ha detto dentro uno slide
domanda ma lei messo porto ferro
tutto questo perché ci sono i gattini
capo
siamo pronti per la boxe mia e poi
qualsiasi potesse questo dovremo di via
dai vediamo un po magro bottino
aranto arancio che fortuna e alla
regione e glitterati cioè qui ma tutti i
leader e tutti colorati questo che cosa
vuol dire che una parte quello che
adesso vi riuscirà un bel galaxy s
arancione più viola grigio vediamo
proprio sta scorrendo lo sta facendo
diventare la proprio di atac siamo una
sci quando guarda ma è cambiato poco è
cambiato però è bello adesso ci mettiamo
questa polvere di stelle che mai e lui
mi darebbe tutto lo rendiamo super
luccicanti super luccicoso
[Musica]
e stupendo
voglio vedere una volta che lo affidiamo
adesso speriamo bene perché guardate il
news live è veramente in condizioni
pietose
se un vulcano di slime non so neanche se
riuscirò ad attivarla comunque dopo
insomma ministeri ma si salva chi no
matri ma l'azione non so se terminazione
per ammorbidirlo un po forza è anche
difficile mischia perché è enorme magari
riuscirò ad attivarlo più velocemente
visto che la metà è già di ed aprile
sono esseri box che dovremmo dividere il
box di mare secondo te cosa c'è qua
dentro e palline bianche a e basta che
mi sembra tutto più
la corte no secondo me qualcosa di più
pesante vediamo una sacca porsche rota
con la immagina con la bianca rosa
chiaro il rosa scuro il problema è che
nella minacciato la non ci stà niente
e poi ora la mia
dobbiamo dividere il partito il suo
bello è proprio bello perché c'è rosa
adesso è ancora più grande fanno
diventare ancora più grigio no cambia
colore e appunto vorrei che ci fosse una
ruota cui possiamo fare scambio adesso
va bene prima o mescolarli il mio sarà
una grande impresa da attivare il tour
sarà facilissimo invece che ne come
secondo è riuscito ad attivarlo questo
mezzo slime sciolto con aggiunta di
coletto al super fu bravo che adesso
però super primi giorni
no rimarrà verde pur tra un mano che
grigio secondo me sì come fa proprio
diritto sino ad attivarlo c'è una cosa
che è un po così che lo vediamo io credo
che cade tutto si che sta diventando
grigio con l'aggiunta del bianco e rosa
il mio padre galaxy ricordiamo ci pensa
la farina del tutto questo è il mio
quasi galaxy si chiamerà così importante
per il boss i galaxy non mi sembra
proprio per niente
ma perché gli manca un po di colore più
scuro l'impatto di parità ai
divertimenti roma quindi iscrivetevi
commenti secondo voi riuscirò ad
attivare il mio fly mood vulcano perde
la vita dall'inizio ad attivare il suo
galaxies liner tillo siamo pronti ad
arrivare lì me li facciamo vedere subito
attivi ora è il mio caso non riuscito ad
attivarlo però è rimasto firth e
ovviamente però non è male perché è
uscito molto grande e fa un po di sony
un po craxi sentite un qualche super
allungabile
[Applauso]
anche per sony sembra un po un albero di
natale quelle con lividi colorate e si
vedono anche i glitter anche se non sono
tantissimi come quelli di vitale
comunque è molto morbido ed estendibile
quindi dategli un voto da 1 a 10 per
rispetto e per sony fmr vediamo è quello
digitale che ospito sto imparando anche
imparato anche a fare costruirli
fatemi l devo dire che non è male sembra
un proprio mega flop del super
bellissimo c'è un colore un po le piazze
prof
devo dire che sì ma che mi piace tanto
mi aspettavo un colore più galaxhar
nattero poi dopo la colla dalla fine
mela un po schiarito adesso sentiamo i
suoni incredibile sentiamo la folle
piace fare il coating egrave
con me sono pure le bolle file cosa
dello stato ha posto la puntina del
sapone slime il colore molto tenue e
l'ho chiamato il gas grazie di frutti di
bosco
sì perché ci sono tanti o galaxy frutti
di bosco da casa è però la farina non si
spende bene infatti dal mio unico paura
era quella ma alla fine che cos'è questa
cosa plasticosa ufficiale su mera
invidia dai suoni ci sono sono mentre i
miei subito sentire bolle senti allora
mi lascio quanto da tempo potete votare
subito io team azzurro non si stacca più
dei capelli e ora milano quattro piatti
linee su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che proprio gli italiani quali siano gli
emilani d'iscrizione
il libro se volete acquistarlo anche voi
su a bordo né un pazzo